hello and welcome to the you're playing
the moss just mossy I cannot really
pronounce it he admissible over the
years so what is he going to do nine BTW
seven okay i still get it back here with
Queenie for now sorry cool it was sore
throat here yeah just d4 I guess that
looks like a quite favorable Catalan so
citroen yeah probably see to make sit
down a bit more difficult time to play
c5 yeah efore is normal here mmm should
be for might be a move I have rookie 17
and not a big deal 85 so what's the
right configuration here and I think it
look a one group d 1 what is he doing
them yeah i think a 3 in problem
some funky setup but at the end i still
prefer FOID for the classical center to
putting my rook on some fancy place
we'll see um 95 is what I'm up to if I
do that you probably goes Bishop to e8
all the way back mmhmm yeah okay I have
time yep okay maybe now that was the
wrong wrong move water it's a little bit
easier no here okay i also have a g5
take sticks e7 is hanging takes takes
Knight takes Knight takes rook takes hmm
not totally convinced by it
d 5 ed ed 95 95 95 octave 5 25 rupees
7mm it should be good for white
if he goes back to be aight i think i'm
just taking e 64 94-95 these kind of
things i also d is six yeah okay i can
just take now him Queen takes has also
Bishop c7 okay so we took with the pawn
okay Bishop h3 is also a good idea to
check the pond is six so immediately
maybe yeah
I might also have the night to defy him
that's a cool reply Wow now that didn't
see that one that's it it's probably
good
okay 95 it's got bishop dear 3595 and
then e 5 should work oh and then it's
got e5 tactical wizard
wow that's awful awful then allowed that
I can take f6 but yes Bishop chicks and
then I've got 94 here we should see to
the zookie a check made
128 yep still time problems
is soooo Bishop f6 I don't really what
does he have something great there i
don't i don't quite see it
yeah it's it's kind of loose all this
but let's see that takes a for IO Quincy
for and take the bishop his bishops are
very strong him check I definitely need
to get rid of that bishop had so much
stronger than the night black resides
and that that's basically also the end
of it if I get this Bishop here okay I
didn't I didn't I shouldn't really have
allowed any complication there the
position was just so overwhelmingly good
yeah this is interesting now d 5 i'm not
really sure i can also just keep the
position and try to improve but it just
looks correct them okay engine agrees so
this was the point that i have this the
computer wants to play differently I'd
PDF at once to take with the rook okay
takes 90 x tix I saw that and I thought
I'm better hear the engine agrees it's
so tricky 1.3 what is the difference
there and take with this I cuz the
routine can take I see mmm we went back
and the engine gives Bishop Bishop age 3
immediately instead of taking of course
he added stronger yeah that's stronger
keeping the tension
this doesn't allow any defiled trades
and Sonia yeah and wide Wincy according
to the comp okay so this is a bit
stronger this also looks good but he has
this look h5 him and now okay not g5 he
has this reply have to go back to f1
which is good of course his bad porn
structure is not going away and his
beard pieces yeah and now we had this
this is funky i dled five very strong I
didn't see that tactic coming okay I
tried this and now he took it after
which everything is good again due to g5
it seems that age six is correct here
according to the computer and it gives
up roughly equal evaluation here yeah
it's rook against um look at Paul
against two pieces and they have weak
light squares this is quite
uncomfortable now I didn't see that
takes and if I but now everything was
back in order yeah night if one is
pretty strong the engine gives this as
the best best way to play 27 and I
looked you one no I wouldn't have played
that one I think I would have taken
which is which is some less convincing I
need a night on safer but it is it i
think it's it's fairly it is not as
difficult as i was thinking because i
have 95 here quite often to to block one
Bishop the way okay okay so Haley fairly
convincing win thanks for watching